the mandalorian is a hit with all ages
but chances are that only the adults in
the audience
will notice these nods references and
details
from references to classic works of
foreign cinema to star wars trivia
here are the things only adults notice
in the mandalorian
although it takes place in a galaxy far
far away the star wars franchise can be
viewed as a study of spaghetti westerns
and samurai movies george lucas has
openly acknowledged the direct influence
films like akira kurosawa's the hidden
fortress
and sergio leones the man with no name
trilogy had on his space cowboy stories
likewise mandalorian creator john
favreau has also cited the two genres
and directors
as major sources of inspiration for his
show he's even been quoted as saying
dinjarin is a deconstructed version of
clint eastwood's iconic the only
character
another major mando inspiration is the
film series lone wolf and cub
sometimes known as shogun assassin in
the u.s this classic story follows a
disgraced shogun's executioner
forced onto the path of an assassin who
must take his young son with him
he pushes a little one around in a
tricked out baby cut
sound familiar although the mandalorian
pulls heavily from the somber tones of
spaghetti westerns and samurai films it
has plenty of laugh out loud moments too
particularly ones poking fun at the star
wars franchise itself
these sarcastic memes are all too
familiar to mature fans
who have been dismantling all the
irregularities and quirks of their
beloved franchise for years
one of the more memorable of these
tongue-in-cheek scenes occurs in chapter
12 the siege while mando grief kaga
kiera dune and the unnamed mithril are
infiltrating an old imperial base on
navarro
the crew encourages the mithril to walk
out on a precarious ledge
over lava to access some machinery
controls to which he replies that
there's no guardrail
a stark lack of safety railings on
empire ships is something star wars fans
have been joking about
since the first film was released in
1977
and was most notably marked in a star
wars parody episode of family guy blue
harvest
so anyway i says forget the dental plan
forget sick leave
i just want a railing you know one
railing right here
another hilarious moment of
self-deprecation in the mandalorian
happens during the cold open of chapter
8 which shows two stormtroopers missing
repeatedly
while firing at a piece of scrap within
close range the scenes playing on the
age-old trope of the notoriously bad
blaster
aim for a guy who never shows his face
din jaron is a huge chick magnet younger
viewers may not notice
but mature audiences will pick up on the
fact that excluding cara dune
the few non-mandalorian females he's
crossed paths with have either been
instantly attracted to him or had some
sort of romantic history with him
in chapter 4 the sanctuary din cross has
passed with a young widow named omara
who seems to want the warrior to settle
down with her bad boy mando also seems
to have broken the heart of xi'an
a knife throwing twilight he works with
in chapter 6 the prisoner
she threatens to use her blades against
him for whatever shenanigans he pulled
on her in the past
adults will likely appreciate the sheer
irony of seeing comedian bill burr cast
in a star wars related role
longtime fans of his podcasts know that
the snarky bostonian has long riffed on
the franchise as he never forged a
personal connection with the original
trilogy
when it was released in his youth burst
stirred up controversy within the star
wars fandom for remarks he made in 2015
declaring that when he did finally watch
the original trilogy in his mid-20s
he wasn't impressed i read a quote that
you had this is a while back i think he
called star wars a cheesy self-help book
put in outer space with much outer space
yeah to be fair bill makes fun of
everyone and everything equally
even his beloved sports team still it
may seem curious that john favreau would
cast a devout star wars hater in the
mandalorian as it turns out
burke claims favreau chose him precisely
for this reason
stating he thought it would be funny
gina carrano's background makes her the
ideal candidate for playing cara dune
the most recent addition to star wars
collection of fierce brunette heroines
before she started acting carano was a
muay thai fighter
who launched her career as one of the
first mainstream female mixed martial
artists
competing back when the sport started
blowing up in the 2000s
after earning an mma record of seven
wins one last and zero draws karano
transitioned into acting in 2008 with
the role of natasha volkova
in ea's real-time strategy video game
command and conquer red alert 3.
her ability to perform her own stunts
and make action look realistic on screen
has kept her busy with various action
roles since
yet another influence bound to be missed
by younger viewers can be seen in
chapter 9 the martial
in which mando travels to the frontier
town of mos palgo on tatooine
seeking out other mandalorians to aid
him on his quest
mando gets sidetracked helping the
marshal destroy a local sand dwelling
monster that has been plaguing his town
known as a greater krait dragon crate
dragons are initially mentioned in star
wars a new hope when obi-wan kenobi
scares up a group of sand people
attacking luke skywalker
by imitating its eerie howl a crate
dragon's bleach skeleton can also be
glimpsed poking out of the tatooine sand
behind c-3po early in the film however
this terrifying beast's appearance on
the mandalorian
references the 1990 sci-fi horror cult
classic
tremors in that movie giant worm-like
creatures called graboids
lurk underground waiting to strike their
next victim when they least expect it
while innocent young minds go no further
than admiring grogoo's core powers and
cuteness factor
adult minds can't tell but wonder where
grogu came from
if he's not a clone as has been implied
in the show thus far then he was
spontaneously created like anakin
skywalker
or he was made the old-fashioned way so
far the only other creatures encountered
like grogu and star wars have been yoda
and yaddle could grogu's existence
explain the latter's sudden
disappearance from the jedi height
council that all remains fan theory for
now
but regardless of who sired the being
formerly known as baby yoda the twisted
adult mind can't help but wonder how
such creatures would accomplish
procreation
awkward it would be yes a pleasant image
it is not
unless you know some kids with very
strange and mature tastes they likely
missed a quick mandalorian reference to
the classic comedy office space
the film parodies all the negative
aspects of toiling away at the dreaded
9-5
cube farm from horrible bosses and
wasting away in traffic
anyone who has ever worked a less than
desirable job can relate to this movie
office space
also makes fun of unnecessary corporate
bureaucracy and paperwork
symbolized by the dreaded tps reports
and the film it's just we're putting new
cover sheets on all the tps reports
before they go out now so if you could
go ahead and
try to remember to do that from now on
that'd be great these reports
seem to have made their way into the
star wars universe because mayfeld
mentions them in chapter 15 the believer
it's such a quick line and easy to miss
come on let's go fill out those tps
reports so we can go recharge the power
coil and you thought the empire was evil
before
chapter 15 is loaded with quentin
tarantino references
mayfeld and mando find themselves in a
dangerous situation
while posing as empire personnel when
officer valen hest insists they join him
for a drink
they risk exposing themselves while
swapping small talk but they can't break
rank by refusing hesse's offer
so they agree the suspenseful scene is
reminiscent of the hair-raisingly
intense bar scene in inglorious bastards
both feature characters infiltrating
enemy cultures while attempting to blend
in as natives
and both situations soon explode into a
violent catastrophe
mando and mayfeld frolic at the empire
bar might also remind an adult viewer of
a scene from django unchained
when dr schultz gives calvin candy a
bullet rather than a requested handshake
just like schultz mayfeld is so overcome
with loathing he can't help but pull the
trigger
and thus puts his companion in grave
danger also like candy hess
has a thick southern accent and a
sinister yet lackadaisical demeanor
a towering villain requires an actor of
serious skill luckily the mandalorians
violin hess is played by a highly
accomplished actor
adults will likely recognize richard
brake brakes succeeds in making his
character absolutely hateful but then as
grown-ups know he has a lot of
experience in that department
break started his acting career in 1993
with a small part as a reporter in a
british comedy drama tv series
jeeves and worcester since then break
has performed in dozens of projects and
at least 30 films spanning all genres
one of his more memorable roles to date
has also been one of his most brief
he was cast as a night king in the
fourth and fifth seasons
of game of thrones check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you